The Joe Rogan Experience
cheese on it
Joe Joe Exotic should be on if she's on
it where's your husband where's your
husband lady
yeah I gotta learn to like make some
money online or something like that
imagine that did she really if if let's
just say if we're not alleging anything
but if she really did feed her husband
to a tiger right you can get her Wishy a
happy birthday that is [ __ ] hilarious
that's how I want to go too is food I
think that's a great way to go out it is
kind of weird that we kind of cheat on
the food thing because we we embalm
ourselves so we don't rock so nothing
can eat us it's a real it's a dirty
trick like the Alligator Pit would be
kind of fun don't you think when your
body's done yeah let's have a little
celebration and throw you in a pit full
of algorithm because they have zero
respect you know the way they roll you
know how they kill you know how they
kill they roll oh that'll be just seeing
myself twerking around like that Jamie
did I show you the video of the
crocodile that's swimming with a body in
its mouth a human body in its mouth
do I send that to you
this one's rough
um I someone sent sent this to me on
Instagram
um it's a crocodile and it's swimming up
to this boat and it sounds like they're
from Australia or South Africa it's hard
to tell
but uh there because I don't I'm not
good at accents but they're um they're
trying to uh figure out what it is and
then they realize it's a human oh no oh
dude it's rough
it's rough I'm gonna try to find okay
this is the kind of stuff
yeah that's a crocodile right oh there
it is on there no that's not no that's
not it that looks good I think I think
they're just showing croc videos they're
not going to show the video I don't
think so let's see this guy's fighting
them off with his videos on Twitter I
guarantee you I have it in here if you
just give me one second I'll find it
extremely graphic footage hear this is
this it
no that's another one oh no
that's another one a month ago I've seen
that one too
bro seriously oh Jesus wow yeah yeah
that's it that's the one wow so look at
that bro that is [ __ ] he depants them
too that is [ __ ] rough by the arm
that is rough and it looks like the
crocodile wants everybody to see it yeah
that's what's most [ __ ] up
now how much swimming over like it wants
everyone to see that it killed a person
now I wanna how much is that crocodile's
Cameo is it bro I just want you to look
at that how crazy that is that is pretty
that we accept the fact that monsters
live near us that we're we're cool with
that like why are we cool with that
what the [ __ ] is wrong with us I think
it puts us like kind of in our place a
little bit you know what I'm saying yeah
is that necessary I get it I don't know
I don't think we should keep those
things around everybody thinks we should
keep them around like I I think shoot
them in the [ __ ] head and turn them
into shoes you're out of your [ __ ]
mind those things eat people like we're
just so far removed from nature that we
think that and I'm not advocating
honestly I'm joking around I'm not
advocating for the elimination of all
crocodiles right but the fact that
people are like really comfortable being
around them it just blows my mind just
like the the Florida is having more and
more alligator attacks every year like
every is that true I might have made
that up but I think there's been a
number this year in Florida well that's
one of my favorite shows where the guys
get to go out and call the herd you know
yeah that's really cool the way they do
that man I love it and uh they're doing
it now with the pythons because that's
another invasive species that show Swamp
People right what is this do happen in
Florida but not in an alarming rate it's
a one is an alarming rate if one one
that's actually gets killed by a
werewolf
one a year gets killed by a werewolf
that's [ __ ] alarming that's not what
that guy thought it was only an average
of 60 years I feel like but I think this
year there was a few I think a few
people died this year how many people
died from alligator attacks in 2022 just
just Google that real quick
I'm gonna guess I think it's six I think
six people have died from alligator
attacks no that's nothing what about
drunk driving what about Oxycontin what
about yeah yeah yeah that too that too
but [ __ ] also alligators four so far
four
how many how many have just [ __ ]
disappeared how many homeless folks just
vanished one of my favorite stories was
a guy stole a car and the cops were
chasing him and he uh jumps out of the
car on a bridge and jumps in the water
and lands right on an alligator and gets
killed right in front of the car oh wow
that's just great landed boom right
where the alligator was just snaps him
up like right away wow uh